[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie Guide happy
Valentine's week I don't know if that's
actually thing but I want to keep the
love going this week because there are
three in these films which each feature
unique love stories all about forbidden
love and I haven't seen these kinds of
love being shown on screen not in this
way before
hopefully that intrigued you because the
first film that I want to talk about is
called love song it's out in theaters
this weekend but I actually saw it at
Sundance in 2016 it's taken a long time
to be released but it was one of my
favorite films back at that festival it
tells a story of a friendship between
two women played by Riley Keough and
Jena Malone they've had a longtime
friendship but when they reconnect it
turns into something more this is a
forbidden love story not just because
they are lifelong friends and what
happens when you cross that boundary but
also because Riley's character is
married with a kid
it's okay to feel a little crazy but
it's not fair to you have to do it all
by yourself
sometime right you want to come it's
directed by so Jung Kim and it's such a
beautiful look at this type of love you
feel the history between them and unlike
other movies which explore female female
friendships which turn into something
more it's very much not for titillation
their love is believable and it's all
part of the story I really enjoyed this
one I can't wait to see it again it's
just a beautiful elegant film so go and
see love song out in theaters this
weekend my second sort of forbidden love
features a character that I've never
seen done on screen before until now
moonlight of course is the film that
I've been going on about for a long time
because I love this movie I saw it last
year I've seen it multiple times since
and of course we've been talking a lot
about moonlight when it comes to Oscars
the film is out on video-on-demand this
week so if you didn't get a chance to
see it in theaters now
is your opportunity where you don't stay
tuned Ava
I like the way this film explores
masculinity you know what does it mean
to be a man and it's amazing to think
that homosexuality wasn't even explored
in American cinema till the 1970s this
movie breaks all those boxes and just
like love song
it's a gorgeous film very subtle and
touching and affecting and trying to
think of more adjectives to describe it
but I really really love this movie
I'm gonna watch it again and again and
again now it's available on video on
demand it's not what I expected
was respect
[Music]
my third unique forbidden love story to
tell you about is called Tana and it's
out on video on demand now this is
Australia's very own best foreign film
nominee at this year's Oscars although
it's all set in Vanuatu it's a very
Romeo and Juliet type tale of forbidden
love this man and this woman who are in
this tribe they love each other but
they're not allowed to get married to
each other because the custom is for
arranged marriages over love marriages
[Music]
[Music]
the film is so beautifully shot and the
actors are magnetic it surprised me when
I looked up the story behind the making
of Tana so the crew involved with Tana
just two people two aziz a cameraman and
a sound guy they went into this tribe
who took them in for seven months while
they improvised scenes and they made
this movie it's just amazing to think
about because before these two guys came
into the tribe they'd never seen a movie
they'd never seen a movie camera they've
never acted or knew what acting was and
all that translates to something very
authentic on-screen I cannot tell that
it was done for such a low budget with
non-professional actors Wow we're
listening and I'm Lucas meet me go
one of em
and you have to go online to watch the
behind-the-scenes making-of Tana because
they ended up showing the completed
movie to this tribe and something really
great about the idea of the first-ever
movie they have seen showing their
stories about their people that's
powerful
they have it three movies about powerful
love stories that are unique and
forbidden you've got love song in
theaters moonlight on video on demand
and Tama on video on demand as always
make sure you tweet me a deletion alone
or write in the comments below about
what you've been watching lately I love
to hear from you guys and I'll see you
soon